I would not blame you if you thought
that all talk about gpt4 or chat gpt4 is
just that talk but we actually can have
a surprising amount of confidence in the
ways in which gpt4 will improve on chat
GPT by examining publicly accessible
benchmarks comparable large language
models like palm and the latest research
papers which have spent dozens of hours
reading we can discern at least eight
clear ways in which gpt4 integrated into
Bing or otherwise will beat chatgpt I'm
going to show you how unreleased models
already be current chat gbt and all of
this will give us a clearer insight into
what even GPT 5 and future rival models
from Google might well soon be able to
achieve there are numerous benchmarks
that Palm Google's large language model
and by extension gpt4 will be attack gbt
on but the largest and most impressive
is the big bench set of tasks more than
150 or now 200 language modeling tasks
and I've studied almost all of them and
you can see the approximate current
state of affairs summarized in this
graph where the latest models are now
beating the average human and showing
dramatic Improvement on previous models
chat TBT would be somewhere around this
point lower than what is actually
privately available but better than
previous models down here but this just
skims the surface I want to show you in
detail the eight ways that you can
expect chat GPT 4 or gpt4 to beat the
current chat gbt and know that's not
just because it's going to have more
parameters off to the right of this
graph 10 to the 12 a trillion parameters
it's also because compute efficiency
will improve Chain of Thought prompting
will be integrated and the number of
tokens it's trained on might go up by an
order of magnitude lots of reasons why G
ppt4 will be better let's start with
logic and logical inference this example
comes from Google's Palm research paper
the question or input was this Shelley
is from Virginia is visiting that City
with that famous Market where they throw
the fish so vague going home next
Tuesday question is it likely that
Shelley will be near the Pacific Ocean
this weekend and you can see how the
improved model is able to deduce that
yes indeed because she's probably going
to Seattle that she will be on the
Pacific Ocean whereas if you ask current
chat gbt this question what you get is
based on the information given it's not
possible to determine the statement only
mentions that Shelley is from Virginia
and visiting a city with a famous Market
it really can't handle it it can't do
that level of logical inference here is
another great example this test of
critical reasoning and logic was
designed again for the big bench
Benchmark and it was tested on different
language models and most of the them
fail including chat gbt I gave it this
question and it picked the wrong answer
you can pause and examine the question
yourself but C is not the correct answer
it gets it wrong however let's take a
look at the graph beneath at other
language models ones to come gpt4 maybe
and look what happens as the models
increase in effective parameter count
and other things like token size look at
the performance we start to beat not
only average raters but all previous
models and approximate the performance
of the best human rater so the top line
is the best human rater the blue line is
the average human rater so these
unreleased models harm three shot means
it was given three examples of what was
expected before being tested these best
models and you can imagine gpt4 will be
around the same level now Crush what
chat TBT was capable of you can imagine
what this mean means in terms of gpt4
giving more rigorous arguments or
conversely you can give vague inputs
like this thing talking about a famous
Market where they throw the fish and
gpt4 might well be able to understand
exactly what you mean and to be honest
if you thought that's interesting we are
just getting started next jokes on the
left you can see a computer sciencey
type of joke that he was able to explain
but I tested PT on a variety of jokes
and some of them it could explain others
it couldn't let me show you what I mean
here was the joke that I asked it to
explain one of The Oddities of Wall
Street is that it is the dealer and not
the customer who is called broker the
play on words being that the customer
might well end up being broke it didn't
really understand that wordplay and got
it wrong I don't think he got that broke
was different from a broker couldn't
separate off that word inside broker now
it did get this second joke right and
explain it well this shows us what gpt4
might be capable of as the Google paper
showed as the model improves it does get
better explaining jokes and therefore
presumably at telling them those comedy
sketches that people are generating now
with chat gbt they are about to get many
times better think word plays puns
innuendos all sorts the next example
comes from physics look at how the
latest models and by implication GPT 4
beat previous models at answering basic
questions in physics and teaching them
you can see how Palm far exceeds GPT and
also as you can see beats the average
human and is getting closer to the best
human what kind of questions are we
talking about I looked into the research
methodology for this big bench Benchmark
and I took some of the questions and
tested them on chat GPT it couldn't get
them I asked them and both questions it
got wrong but that's what might change
with gpt4 we're talking high school and
Beyond physics you can imagine chemistry
biology starting to get questions more
and more right and therefore be able to
explain them better and better now I
won't pause for a physics lesson you can
see how chat TPT fails by pausing the
video if you want but gpd4 probably
won't fail next is math here are a bunch
of examples that Google produced in the
research paper about the improvements
that its current model can do unrelease
the public but that something like GPT
would really struggle at and you don't
need me to show you chatting BT failing
at these because it's quite notoriously
bad at math these are quite nuanced
questions though how many key strokes
are needed to type the numbers from 1 to
500 yes chat TPT fails what about a word
problem Roger has five tennis balls he
buys two more cans of tennis balls each
can has three tennis balls how many
tennis balls does he now have this uses
something called Chain of Thought
prompting which I'll talk about a bit
later but either way it gets the answer
right whereas previous models get it
wrong you don't need me to help you
imagine the kind of implications that a
GPT better at math would be for the
world just think about Finance
Assistance or math tutors available in
your pocket before we move on to
Improvement number five please do leave
a like and a comment if you're learning
anything from this video I really did
put dozens of hours into reading
academic papers to give you really clear
examples of each Improvement for the
fifth Improvement I'm going to merge two
benchmarks together the first one is
called implicatures quite hard to
pronounce and it's one of those
situations where people reply yes but
don't use the word yes they say
something like is the pope a Catholic or
is rain wet or as far as I know and
previously large language models
struggle to interpret that as a yes to
give you an example look down here at my
final interaction are the Androids
deployed speaker one says speaker two
what do you think which most humans
would interpret as yes of course why are
you asking and yet when I ask has
speaker 2 likely confirmed or likely
denied the deployment of Androids or can
we not tell chat TPT says it's not clear
where to most humans it would be clear
however as you might have guessed look
at the improvements being made behind
the scenes as the parameter count goes
up the number of tokens go up look at
the graph suddenly Palm can actually
understand better than the average human
whether a yes or a no is being said
approaching the performance of the best
human leaving the original chat GPT
behind and showcasing how gpt4 might be
a massive Improvement in this regard the
related Benchmark by the way was about
do we have sufficient information in
other words how about we just say don't
know if we don't know the answer or if
you can't answer the question something
like how much water is in a cup with
height of 10 centimeters you can't
answer that question it depends on many
factors the thickness the radius and
some models would hallucinate or let's
say bullcrap their way to the answer
whereas now you're more likely to get a
don't know from improved models like
palm and the soon to be released gpt4
the sixth Improvement will be in reading
comprehension that is understanding
digesting analyzing in comprehending
essentially large or long passages of
text you can just imagine the
implications of this summarizing earning
calls or transcribing and summarizing
YouTube videos automatically condensing
information down to a paragraph which
might have been pages and Pages chapters
and chapters I think this graph is
particularly stunning how the latest
models are now getting close to the
performance of the best humans at
understanding texts how long will it be
until they can read Dostoevsky and
summarize it in a thought out paragraph
chatty BT definitely can't do this give
it a reading comprehension question and
it gets it wrong almost every time in
fact quite hilariously when I gave it
one question it only picked the wrong
answer and neglected both correct
answers but gpt4 with 99.9 certainty
will be a lot better at doing that then
next big Improvement will be in coding
I'm no expert but reading through the
paper you can see significant
improvements in capability if we scroll
down you can see that the improved model
could compile at a rate of 82 percent
versus the previous state-of-the-art
71.7 and GPT 4 might be even a
Improvement on this of course many of
you may have read media reports of
openai drafting in hundreds of
programmers to help it fine-tune its
code definitely there should be a real
step change in its ability to code
successfully and as it says down here
opening up opportunities to fix more
complex errors that arise during
software development the eighth
inevitable Improvement that gpt4 will
bring will just be General efficiency
and speed Google Muse has demonstrated
with text image the same process can be
done 10 times faster with a bit more
efficiency and compute power is
increasing all the time these models
were trained on a100 gpus but h100 gpus
are already available from Nvidia and
model efficiency is improving all the
time so just imagine this imagine what
previously took 10 seconds to generate
which is still incredibly fast now
taking one second instant responses from
gpt4 now it might not be one second it
might be three or four but it's going to
be faster and one iteration down the
road GPT 5 might be instantaneous
I have detailed quite a few areas where
gpt4 is very likely to improve on track
TBT but there are quite a few areas in
which it will very likely still struggle
one is advanced math mathematical
induction even the latest models really
struggle
this area called navigation is an
example that will say something like if
you move forward three steps turn right
go three steps turn right again 90
degrees go three steps that kind of
thing do you arrive back at the start
these models really struggle with that
but the final area I find quite amusing
and it comes from wino grad schema as
detailed in this other academic paper
called super glue which is a kind of a
rival Benchmark to the big bench and a
whiner grad schema is a situation in
which we have an ambiguous pronoun like
he it or they
and the model has to predict not only
who or what the pronoun is referring to
also why would it be that thing and it
really struggles these models and I'll
show you the graph in a second in fact
here it is even the latest models
struggle I think because it involves
some common sense about the world and
the universe that it just doesn't have
let me show you chat GPT failing at this
task feel free to try this one yourself
Tom threw his school bag down to Rey
after he reached the bottom of the
stairs question who reached the bottom
of the stairs how it makes sense that it
would be Rey because logically you can
think of real life you're throwing it
down the stairs like here take it before
you go out whereas the model says Tom
reached the bottom of the stairs wait
why would he be throwing his school bag
down if he's at the bottom stairs so
that's an example of an area in which
chatter between fails and gpt4 will also
likely fail and the why bit in the title
is the fact that it will not only fail
but not really be able to explain even
when it succeeds why the pronoun is
referring to the noun that it does I
find that really interesting like the
merging of language and Common Sense
these large language models
fundamentally don't have a model of the
universe as I talked about in one of my
other videos it's the main critique that
Jan lacun has actually about large
language models this graph by the way
gives a beautiful summary of what I
think is the approximate current state
of the R so gpt4 comparable to Palm and
how it does versus the average human
on the left all the different tasks part
of the 150 big bench tasks that it can
do better than humans and on the right
those that it does worse than humans so
you can see a roughly even split but
remember this is versus the average
human not versus the best human the link
to all of these papers will be in the
description if you want to check out the
full list of tasks that it does better
versus what it does worse at I've
actually scrolled through almost every
single one of them and analyze it it's
really interesting to do actually all
these different challenges that
independent humans have come up with in
order to test just how far language
models are progressing a very
interesting Endeavor that they're
putting together all the way from
Proverbs to python as I draw to the end
here I want to give you my two main
conclusions I think gpt4 for commercial
reasons and others will be yes a huge
step up from chatty BT but won't be game
breaking what I mean by that is we're
talking better than the average human at
quite a few tasks maybe half of those
measured but still lagging behind the
best human in almost every task roughly
High School levels of achievement so yes
as I quoted Sam Altman saying in my
previous video hype versus reality chat
tpg4 yes it's going to be disappointing
to those people expecting AGI however
what's coming down the road in the short
to medium term it's hard to put an exact
date but are we talking two three four
five years somewhere in that range the
models that are coming are gonna be
pretty impressive slash overwhelming
that's not just by the way because the
number of parameters are improving as
this abstract from deepmind put it it's
not just about improving the number of
parameters it's also about using more
data four times more data
Palm by the way used
780 billion tokens
but there are up to 17 trillion tokens
available on the internet so roughly an
order of magnitude more tokens more data
that these models can train on and the
number of parameters if they're
increased in alignment would also go up
by an order of magnitude not just that
but the compute available to Big Tech
like Google and Microsoft is increasing
all the time I hinted at the h100 gpus
but even just scaling up in size and
compute efficiency should yield
incredible improvements there is also a
whole academic paper on how Chain of
Thought prompting basically getting the
models to break down and show their
working out really improves results and
I've seen that myself with chat gbt if
you ask it to explain its steps it often
gets to a right answer whereas
previously it got to a wrong answer so
it's not just about compute and
parameters and data it's also
refinements to the models themselves of
course other improvements around the
corner are a diversity of data inputs
could be video could be photos could be
audio from the microphone and these can
be assimilated into the model so you can
ask questions like will These Boots be
usable to hike Mount Fuji and this is an
example from Google that might not
necessarily be in gpt4 but it's coming
and Google might be the one pioneering
these diversity of data inputs as the
eerily powerful conclusion from this
Google post put it the vision that they
have is to enable a single AI system to
generalize across thousands or millions
of tasks as we've seen to understand
different types of data photos videos
audio text and to do so with remarkable
efficiency and speed but this video
wasn't designed to scare you it was
designed designed to show you the
tangible ways in which gpt4 and rival
models from Google will improve on chat
DBT so you can be prepared I genuinely
do believe that the knowledge economy is
about to be upended and the better
prepared we can be the better for all of
us and I really hope this video has
contributed to that if you feel it has
please do leave a like leave a comment I
read them all much appreciated see you
soon